[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magacín informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre es
liliana valencia y aquí damos una mirada
en profundidad a los hechos de
actualidad de la semana en la cuna de la
humanidad
en sudáfrica el gobierno suspendió el
uso de la vacuna contra el cob y 19 de
astrazéneca después de que estudios
demostraron que dio una protección
mínima contra la variante originada en
ese país esto después de que la nación
austral decidiera el primer cargamento
de medicamentos
marruecos fue uno de los primeros países
del continente africano en iniciar la
vacunación contra el 19 con los fármacos
destino farm y astrazéneca fue el
primero en recibir la vacuna del rey
mohamed sexto y posteriormente empezó la
inmunización del personal sanitario
tenemos reportes desde marrakech
y aficionados al fútbol en marruecos
también celebraron la victoria de su
equipo en el campeonato africano de
naciones en camerún la selección
marroquí de ligas venció 2 por 0 a malí
y logró un segundo título consecutivo
algo nunca antes visto en este torneo
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días porque el
gobierno de sudáfrica suspendió el uso
de la vacuna contra el cob y 19
astrazéneca en su programa de vacunación
después de que estudios demostraron que
hay una protección muy baja cuando la
variante originada en ese país las
autoridades de salud informaron sobre
qué hacer con esta vacuna previamente
hablamos con nuestro corresponsal en
sudáfrica salem fayad acerca de la
variante que está circulando en esta
nación del sur del continente africano
sudáfrica ha sufrido un duro revés en la
lucha contra la pandemia apenas este mes
llegaron un millones de dosis de la
vacuna de astrazéneca pero un estudio
reciente de la universidad de
witwatersrand ha demostrado que esta
vacuna no es lo suficientemente eficaz
para atacar la nueva variante del virus
la variante 501 b2 identificada
inicialmente aquí en sudáfrica es más
infecciosa y es la predominante aquí en
el país y la respuesta del gobierno no
se ha hecho esperar el ministro de salud
zweli mkhize ha declarado que se
suspenderá entonces el programa de
vacunación con la vacuna de astrazéneca
pero que el programa no se suspenderá
del todo en su lugar se usará la vacuna
johnson y johnson que según estudios
preliminares es más eficiente contra
esta nueva variante el país espera
entonces que para las próximas semanas
lleguen 9 millones de dosis de la vacuna
de johnson y johnson y unos 20 millones
adicionales de la vacuna de facer el
gobierno ha declarado también que está
acelerando la llegada estas nuevas dosis
para empezar un programa de vacunación
que ya está de por sí bastante
en el país más afectado por la pandemia
en el continente marruecos también
inició campaña de vacunación con sus
ciudadanos en contra del coi 19
fármacos de scinopharm y astrazéneca el
primero en recibir la vacuna fue el rey
mohamed sexto
posteriormente empezó la campaña de
vacunación en diferentes centros fijos y
unidades móviles del país donde las
dosis se administrarán de manera
gratuita hay unos 2.800 puntos fijos
ubicados en centros hospitalarios
universidades y lugares de trabajo y
otros 7000 móviles habilitados para la
tarea el proceso prevé dar prioridad a
los grupos más vulnerables y al personal
sanitario
sofía catalanes a corresponsables en
marruecos nos amplió la información
acerca de las campañas de vacunación en
este país del norte del continente
marruecos es el primer país de áfrica
que ha empezado a recibir las vacunas
anti covite 19a el gobierno marroquí
tuvo que fletar un vuelo hacia la india
para recoger dos de los 22 millones de
dosis encargadas a la británica
astrazéneca y se espera recibir otros 40
millones de vacunas de la china sino
pharma a partir del próximo día 27 de
enero el ministerio de sanidad ha
anunciado que la campaña de vacunación
ha empezará ya la semana próxima
empezarán a vacunar primero al personal
sanitario y educativo mayor de 45 años a
las autoridades públicas al personal
militar las personas enfermas y las
personas mayores de 70 años el resto de
la población será vacunada
progresivamente a medida que vayan
llegando a las dosis necesarias según ha
informado el ministerio de sanidad
las vacunas también se administrarán a
de forma voluntaria y gratuita a todas
las personas residentes en marruecos y
se puede empezar a pedir turno a partir
de este domingo vía sms a través de la
plataforma licor
o en los puestos de atención ciudadana y
según ha informado también el ministerio
de sanidad a las personas vacunadas se
les dará un documento que incorporará un
código qr que deberán presentar ante las
autoridades en caso de necesidad
y es que mientras las naciones ricas del
mundo acapara las existencias en una
carrera por garantizar la vacunación del
100 por ciento de su población los
países africanos luchan por obtener la
mayor cantidad de dosis posible pero con
retos adicionales como la falta de
recursos y de infraestructura logística
según la organización mundial de la
salud se espera que hasta el 30 por
ciento de la población del continente
esté vacunada para finales de este año
egipto 6 eles y mauricio fueron los
primeros países africanos en lanzar
campañas de vacunación contra el hobbit
19 las dos primeras de estas naciones
usaron el medicamento desarrollado por
la farmacéutica china sino farm mientras
que mauricio está utilizando la fórmula
de kobe shield fabricada en india y
donada por ese país en marruecos el
antídoto inyectado al rey dio inicio a
la campaña nacional y argelia comenzó a
inocular la vacuna rusa sputnik de hace
algunos días con la distribución será en
todos los estados de la nación si dios
quiere en 48 estados y continuará
durante todo el año de manera organizada
científica y precisa
se espera que sudáfrica comience su
campaña en dos semanas según la
organización mundial de la salud el 30
por ciento de la población de áfrica
podría vacunarse antes de fin de año con
una aceleración a mediados de febrero
cuando se entreguen las primeras de las
670 millones de vacunas solicitadas en
el contexto de la iniciativa kóvacs
billy beane tenemos muchas esperanzas de
que las primeras dosis comiencen a
distribuirse en áfrica probablemente a
mediados del próximo mes y en marzo sin
duda veremos que la mayoría de los
países comenzarán a vacunar ambos
urticantes taxing a rating pero incluso
si la o ms alcanza su objetivo del 30
por ciento al menos el doble de personas
necesitarían vacunarse para lograr la
inmunidad colectiva áfrica se salvó
relativamente la primera ola de kobe
pero ahora hay más de 3.5 millones de
casos confirmados sin embargo expertos
creen que esta cifra está por debajo de
la realidad con muchos pacientes que
confunden los síntomas de covite con los
de la malaria
y otros países de áfrica sub-sahariana
ya avanzar en la consecución de vacunas
y esperar iniciar pronto sus respectivas
campañas uno de ellos es kenia cuyo
gobierno presentó un ambicioso plan de
vacunación que iniciará en las próximas
semanas
el gobierno de kenia informó que está
buscando 11 millones de dosis
adicionales de vacunas contra el cob y
19 además de los 24 millones ya
ordenados y espera tener 16 millones de
personas vacunadas para junio de 2022
fax fácil genia es miembro de la
instalación kóvacs y se ha comprometido
inicialmente a adquirir vacunas a través
de ese mecanismo y con este compromiso
el país recibirá 24 millones de dosis y
adquirirá 11 millones más de otros
mecanismos para vacunar a casi 16
millones de personas muy orondos es
decir el 30 por ciento de nuestra
población durante un período de 18 meses
heitmann procedente de los principales
fabricantes farmacéuticos como pfizer y
johnson and johnson las dosis
adicionales se adquirirán a través del
organismo de prevención y control de
enfermedades de la unión africana
autoridades de salud esperan recibir las
primeras dosis la segunda semana de
febrero
michelle entre febrero y junio de 2021
estamos apuntando a 125 millones de
personas
esto se debe a la escasez de vacunas que
hay en este momento las personas que se
cubrirán en la fase 1 incluirán a los
trabajadores de atención médica de
primera línea ya todo el personal que
están trabajando en establecimientos de
salud tanto en el sector público como en
el privado también hemos priorizado para
la fase 1 a los trabajadores que están
prestando servicios esenciales en
sectores prioritarios como seguridad
inmigración y presión la segunda fase de
la vacunación e involucraría a 9,7
millones de ciudadanos priorizando a las
personas mayores de 50 años la tercera
fase se desarrollará al mismo tiempo que
la segunda y estará dirigida a 4,9
millones de personas residentes en
regiones congestionadas
vamos con información deportiva porque
marruecos celebró su segunda victoria
consecutiva en el campeonato africano de
fútbol que tuvo lugar en camerún a miles
de aficionados se tomaron las calles de
las principales ciudades del país
norteafricano para celebrar la victoria
de su equipo la selección marroquíes de
ligas venció 2 por 0 a malí y logró su
segundo título consecutivo algo inédito
en este torneo los marroquíes expresaron
su alegría ante la victoria
aunque la primera parte fue un poco
difícil marcaron dos bonitos goles a
marruecos
por la gracia a camerún por su
hospitalidad sobre todo por el juego
limpio la competencia está bien
organizada esto es una prueba para la
copa africana de naciones estamos
seguros de que será un éxito con 24
tipos todo irá bien los cameruneses
están contentos nosotros estamos
contentos gracias gracias gracias
a continuación más noticias destacadas
de la semana aquí en france 24
la corte penal internacional declaró
este jueves culpable al ex comandante
ugandés del ejército de resistencia del
señor dominique power de 61 crímenes de
guerra y de lesa humanidad entre los
delitos cometidos por owen se encuentran
ataques contra la población civil
asesinato tortura persecución esclavitud
matrimonio forzado embarazo forzado y
reclutamiento de menores
live anunció la conformación de un nuevo
gobierno interino y la celebración de
elecciones nacionales en diciembre de
este año como resultado de las
conversaciones auspiciadas por naciones
unidas el objetivo es resolver una
década de conflictos armados primero
tras el derrocamiento de muamar al
gadafi y posteriormente entre las
fuerzas del este del país y el gobierno
en trípoli hasta ahora reconocido
internacionalmente
y en egipto las autoridades liberaron al
periodista mahmud husein tras más de 4
años de detención el reportero del canal
catarí al yazira se encontraba en
prisión preventiva y sin juicio desde el
23 de diciembre de 2016 cuando fue
acusado de difundir noticias falsas en
2010 y luego en tribunal ordenó su
puesta en libertad pero se le implicó en
un nuevo caso por cargos relacionados
con con terrorismo
y finalizamos con música que nos llega
desde el congo del cantante filipa
presentó su nueva canción titulada ancap
una colaboración con el también
reconocido artista that you
cuba sorprendió a sus seguidores con una
canción llena de energía y un vídeo de
alta calidad que muestran la belleza de
la mujer africana resalta los ritmos
tradicionales del país con esta buena
música finalizamos este capítulo de
áfrica siete días ustedes pueden
continuar con más nuestra página web
france24 puntocom nos vemos más adelante
con más información que deben ser esto
es trans 24
[Música]
el límite de la mamá
este conjunto
m
[Música]
la noche clic agua agua
yo no hago ninguna no hablamos del
franquismo que tampoco dejó de las
últimas y más conviene poner en común el
medio tema
muy bien
[Música]